california is used to wildfires
but nothing like this the scale is
unparalleled
an area five times the size of new york
is currently burning
just ten percent of one fire has been
brought under control
and you see the cruel lottery of what's
left
one house narrowly missed while in
neighbors
lost everything
brian has lived here for more than 40
years
a family home he watched go up in flames
it came over the top of these mountains
and it just flowed like a river of fire
down the hill and across the valley and
i had about three hours to get
everything out that i could
before i left i stood there and watched
it burn
and there was no fire department
anywhere because they were
apparently saving lives up the valley
trying to evacuate people but
yeah it's pretty heartbreaking to see it
your whole life just go up in flames
firefighters are so stretched they've
had to prioritize which fires to fight
but that doesn't make it any easier when
it's your life memories
reduced to ashes firefighters haven't
been able to even attempt
to save some homes and it's little
wonder they're currently fighting four
times more fires right now than they did
in the whole of last year and state
resources
are stretched to a capacity they've
never seen before
units from as far as texas are bringing
help
but that's a two to three day journey by
road
more lightning strikes and gusty winds
have threatened to make this situation
even worse and the help
can't come soon enough based on our
resources we got a lot of out of state
resources coming
and they're being split up among all the
fires
and just to make sure that we can get a
handle on this
but you're here for the long haul
correct i'll probably be here for the
next month
this on top of record temperatures means
relief is coming
no time soon the governor is among many
warning this is down to climate change
but as people are left to pick up the
pieces of their torched lives
there's no evacuation plan from the
worsening trend
of wildfires in the state sally lockwood
sky news
vacaville in northern california